congrats on this show I find it so
extremely necessary to watch a little
behind the scenes life of therapists
what's it like for you working on a big
comedy like this that's really kind of
laughing us out of our seats and
heartwarming us at the same time well I
I I I I I
enjoy doing comedy it's really fun
and the people that I'm working with are
fantastic the writers are terrific the
actors are great I'm having a ball
this thing kind of gives us a look
behind the scenes a little bit of
therapists what was your take coming
into the show on therapy and then did it
change at all
well I don't know that much about
therapy but uh you know but I did my
homework and I uh I think I got a
behavioral modification therapy down
uh and it makes sense to me it doesn't
uh
I don't think he'd get me there but it
makes sense to me
you're doing you're doing you're serving
us uh some much needed comedy therapy
through this show we appreciate it so
much
um I want to shift gears a little bit
everybody's talking about Indiana Jones
everybody's excited about it but I want
to mention Ki Qui Quan who just got
nominated
what's it like to watch him achieve
these great things in Hollywood happy
for him he's a great great guy and uh
he's a wonderful actor he was when he
was a little kid and he still is I'm
glad to I'm very happy for him I would
love to see him do you think it's at all
possible for him to cameo in one of the
future indie films that'd be great
be great
I know you can't talk much about this
but 1923 is another thing you have so
many things going on anything you can
tease us with besides there's horses on
the show
no I mean I this these stories will spin
out over the next uh next
four or five uh episodes and then and
next year I think uh I mean I really
don't know where we're going in the
second season
but I'm I've learned to trust Taylor
Sheridan
30 years since the fugitive came out one
of my all-time favorite movies you got
any memories from that set anything you
you remember oh yeah I mean I
I've uh it's it's one of my favorites
too
I don't think I've got anything new uh
that I can tell you about it
but uh yeah I really admire it and I I
was really glad I am glad I have it in
the
in my uh
yeah right repertoire